okay so historically men had to ensure  paternity  there wasn't there wasn't paternity  tests historically right and that's  that's new modern medicine so  if a man dated a girl that slept around  he wasn't he could potentially pass on  resources to a kid that was not his so  that's the biological reason why men  have evolved to not like girls that have  slept around however women it's the  opposite we have evolved two like men  that have slept around for example Drake  he's had a kid with a corn star  and he he clearly sleeps around yet  there are women lined up I mean so right  I okay there are other factors that go  into that there's other factors but but  you understand my point right where  Brittany Renner or whatever the you know  I'm talking Runner Brittany Runner there  aren't men and Mia Khalifa there are not  men lined up to date them